please welcome sam richardson
you know i feel like we should call this
after party week um because um egg baron
holtz was uh here
um promoting the after party i love him
so much yeah he's the best what a great
person truly and then alana glaser is
coming on the show as well she's also in
the cast a wonderful wonderful person so
funny and it's a really fun format where
well maybe you should tell them
well it's a high school reunion murder
mystery who'd done it
where uh everybody has their 15-year
high school reunion
and
uh dave franco plays the character
xavier with the pop star yeah z-x x-x
x-x or xavier we don't know which way to
go uh he dies and it becomes a mystery
because like no one knows who did it so
uh each episode is then told uh
the events of the night are told through
each person's perspective and each
perspective is a different genre of film
yes so you may have an action movie or a
suspense thriller or my episode my
character anik is a a rom-com yes which
i of course loved because i love a good
rom-com yeah i mean i do love i love i
love a rom-com you know just
just uh optimism and and
beautiful lighting sort of like crane
shots that are you know very beautiful
uh rainy kisses
sort of thing i love a rainy kiss you
know what i love so much when like
someone puts their hands on your face
where's that move yeah where did that go
it needs to be brought back it does i
think uh hand sanitizer you know it kind
of breaks the mood if you're like hold
on
[Laughter]
you're right
that's my guess you're totally right um
okay well uh everybody knows you also
from veep like what was it like working
on that show everybody loved it she was
such an iconic character there's richard
i love that expression by the way it's
so cute it's so loaded sorry right and
it's just so innocent and like naive but
like he he believes that everybody has
the best intentions you know which
is not the case on that show
and that's why we love it okay
my daughters and i have seen hocus pocus
i don't know how many times let's call
it hundreds
tell us you're are you filming it right
now oh we just wrapped up
[Applause]
i like the after party beef okay um it's
so hard there are so many exciting
things what is hocus pocus to like it
was great and then the ladies are all
back and they haven't missed a step they
are so incredible and i always get to
watch you know my scenes with them i'm
watching it as a fan so i'm just like
yeah it's oh that's so cool because they
like you know they have they're so
coordinated and funny and like they play
off of each other so well and i was just
like kind of watching it through the
little you know the the little
viewfinder in the camera and i'm just
like
that's great i'm like oh that's right my
response but it was really a fun thing
to get to do and just like me outside of
myself watching myself be in that movie
dream come true uh people are fans of
that movie people are fans of it it
really is beloved yeah i'm so excited
well i can't wait will you like please
come back and talk about that movie when
it comes out i
promise i will absolutely
[Music]